that's right here we are sometimes when
a movie comes out I want to talk a
little more about that movie a little
more in-depth talking about spoilers as
is the case with alien covenant this is
your spoiler warning if you don't want
spoilers probably leave now as always I
have a spoiler free review can check
that out come back after you see in the
movie why we don't give a [ __ ] hey stick
around the point in spoilers coming at
you so an alien covenant as I said my
spoiler free review it's basically it's
a colony mission or a couple thousand
colonists in this ship they're all in
bleak hypersleep their stasis and the
ship gets the signal which is music
can't remember the song or the artist
didn't forget it wrong though those
audio files are coming at me who's going
to say his Bob Dylan which is pretty
advantageous for them to go investigate
one because it's on a planet though like
wow this is way better than the planet
we were going to it's also closer and
there's music from Earth playing there
that's why let's go there to check it
out step on some spores and sports go in
their ears and aliens Bluffs out of
their backs and I have a bit of a horror
movie Fassbender standing there and he
shoots a flare in the skies I come with
me if you want to do Fassbender plays
two roles in here David and Walter both
androids and in my spoiler free review
actually had a part where I talked about
how they remind me of data and lore
because they totally remind me of data
and lore however then I realized that by
cullism data and lore I am saying fast
vendors character is actually an evil
[ __ ] kind of a spoiler you figured he
would be but still for spore is a free
stick it took it out but yeah they're
totally data in long yeah David's a bit
of a creepy on business little [ __ ]
he has dialogue with Walter Walters like
after your model I decided to make my
model with less complication less human
attributes would you see at the
beginning of this movie Guy Pearce
whaling he's sitting down he's talking
with David they're having some
back-and-forth David's playing the piano
and they had Boyd Davis like well if
you're going to die and I'm gonna live
how are you above me exactly switch
Weiland was like give me some tea tea is
like right next to him it just like this
power movie does until right there
David's like [ __ ] this guy if ever an
opportunity comes where I can create
some parasitic murder beast I'm gonna
make it big thing about this movie that
bums me out is you don't actually get
Prometheus to Prometheus ends where
Elizabeth Shaw has David's head and his
body and she's like we're going to the
engineers planet we're going to get some
answers this is the engineers planet but
you don't get the answer so you find out
David's killed her and he just hovers
the craft above their city drops that
payload of [ __ ] that we're going to drop
on us and now they're all dead or no
here none at all which is a bummer in a
world where I like answers but I suppose
does make sense for the studio's point
of view in Ridley Scott so it's like
alright
Prometheus half like it half didn't
alien everyone like that so let's go the
alien route and who gives a [ __ ] about
Prometheus I do a lot of answers if
you're going the whole route of we were
created by these engine tears and the
theme of created surpassing the creator
god complex I feel like it's relevant
enough to go ahead and give us a sensor
so we get for the most part this is a
dead planet remember in my review I was
like there is a scene of movies like
something is missing this is the missing
this is the thing that could be its own
movie
the bummer is it'll be a fast movie it's
like in the end what we saw happen in
the explanation is what happens the
movie would be Fassbender kills
Elizabeth Shaw and then dumps the
payload and kill the planet it's a
pretty quick movie which is why it just
feels a little sloppy if not unfulfilled
I guess is the word also I feel like a
lot of Prometheus is irrelevant the
thing that carries over from Prometheus
to now is David engineers don't really
carry over that xenomorph thing that
came out of the engineer at the end of
Prometheus that doesn't really carry
over and matter whole day was a fool
really and that's how they were created
now not really
aliens were created because you find out
David is some super mad scientist who's
done experiments that he mix this and
that he created something that's almost
perfect but not quite so he mixed more
and it's his mad experiments that make
the xenomorph you can see Elizabeth
Shaw's dead body oh he used her too man
is moving civilization forward also the
alien imagery and Prometheus you know
there's D no more affections on the
wallet no how was because they're not
really from there they're David's
creation that he's going to do later
how are those they're his alien movie
are they going to move into time travel
I feel like that's the only way you
could really wrap it all up at the end
of the movie he perfected he's like
check this out Billy Crudup come here
this space hugger egg opens up be like
good [ __ ] does there's like that's fine
fine Billy Crudup like alright alien
scientist here week I'll click it and
then it's done passes out alien bus out
of his so which is really it's different
now alien one man even aliens like the
aliens busting out of people please oh
you start convulsing it's just like a
whole thing a ha [ __ ] ha ha
it's so super violent this one Billy
Crudup slain on the ground is like huh I
was asleep what'd you do to me
wow I was like did you not feel that
coming out bad you're a topic maybe he
has FIFA I don't know I saw it on house
1 so now at the end of the movie the end
the xenomorph is created and the thing
is this raging havoc and killing people
which does make me torn on one hand this
thing is the perfect organism has always
been said to be the perfect organism
ever since Ian Holm and the first alien
says you can't kill it is a perfect
organism however I like the concept
where it's just kind of natural
selection it's just the natural
evolution of life in the galaxy it's
like gab people you're not that tough
you're not that big a deal there's
things out there that are much worse it
makes you think there are things out
there we should not find at the end of
this movie David and Walter get into a
scuffle you don't see who's dead which
right there you're like I'm pretty sure
I know who lived in the end of it when
they're all going with their states
asleep Walters Walter it's like alright
sleep well she knows it's David she
starts crying freaking out and he just
barfs up these little things if they
have fetuses in he's puts them where the
fetuses are they're facehuggers music I
got my face huggers with the babies I'm
going to go ahead and keep an eye on the
ship and the crew and make sure this
colony Worth's a hive of the most
perfect organisms inside of a galaxy
yeah they're all [ __ ] however we still
don't see how it ties in to alien yet
I've not seen lv-426 don't know how that
ship got on lv-426 has to be tied with
David because the eggs that are seen on
lv-426 are the same eggs that David
himself created so wherever this
Prometheus alien covenant story arc is
going it has to end there and it
probably will six movies from now I like
seeing the xenomorph I really did I
liked how they just made that xenomorph
terrifying because that's how the
xenomorph is supposed to be it's
supposed to be very terrifying but
there's a part of me that does wish we
could have gotten the payoff to the
point of prometheus I mean the movie
does have great themes about God complex
what is God what is creator what is
creator if he becomes obsolete by the
created what does the Creator think if
the created if the disappointments like
you know the engineers were disappointed
in us obviously David is like no my
creations are amazing hats off to James
Franco and his performance or at least
his paycheck they paid him to be in one
webisode
or trailer or clip on YouTube let's
blame the system my man good job right
guys so alien covenant have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]